hey what's up Samuel leaves here and
this is a video for our certified
partners to teach you how to get a
runner while lying on your bed at home
like I'm doing right now tomorrow we've
got some we've got some viewings in
Grimsby and we've got a few things books
I can't go no one can go so we need a
runner how do you get a run out last
minute here we go watch this this will
blow you a way so first I'm going to
show my screen you can just do this at
home while on your bed so boom you
should now be able to see my screen
alright here goes
first thing you need to do is you need
to go on to a website called spare room
doctor at UK which by now should be your
new best friend so don't spare room and
what you're gonna want to do is you're
gonna want to find and then there's two
types of people that'll be a really good
runner one is a property HMO manager
they'll be really good winners because
they'll be able to specify this to me
but hmm or not secondly will be a
builder a local builder because they're
gonna know how much work it's gonna need
so we're gonna start by looking at
agents so if we type here Grimsby
Grimsby rooms for rent search now and we
can see here that we've got lots of
rooms available so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna type in at the top and
click where it says agents only it's
been send an agent who could potentially
get business from it I think certainly
as a first port of call so we see all
these properties in Grimsby we've got
here 85 pound a week 65 to 70 pounds and
you can click on these and you can
actually say that here we go
unity lettings phone advertiser that's
their number gilma call burn they might
be able to view it for you I'll tell you
what to say in a moment when you call
them but there's absolutely loads and
also you can see a lot of these I mean
the products that we're looking at is
this one 65 grams
all bad house looks like it's in good
condition
floor plans is great he had five
bedrooms out of there one two
that would count as one one two three
and then downstairs four five so it's
great it's a good area it's in DN 3 2
and we can see here that some of these
guys are also in D and 3 2 which is
perfect
the rooms are going a 100 pound a week
95 pound a 800 pound a week and these
are actually less which is crazy that
it's in D and 3 2 and they're renting
out for that much with the house so
cheap so we really just want to get a
second opinion and HMO manager is the
best person this is another one new
mills properties boom
oK we've got no number but what we can
do instead is we can actually just
Google these guys new mills properties
and then Shaba we've got their number
okay they're close now but that's not
the point
I on four seven two three six zero one
six eight so you can do this and you can
get so many different people's contact
details of leyte
hmm managers nearby they're just
brilliant brilliant brilliant runners
next build us what do you do
wow you just literally type in Builder
Grimsby here we have a whole bunch of
builders I mean there's just so many to
choose from
why fight is a little bit slow but you
get the idea just google Grimsby
builders and you'll see what there's so
much this directory after directory so
the question is okay we've got the - all
these guys
there are as these are all in Grimsby
got their numbers got everything about
them Lee Easter and some zero seven
seven one seven one six two four two
nine so when you call them what do you
say if they're a letting agent I would
probably say something like this because
you're going to want to break your way
in you can't just rest straight you know
got a house can you move for me tomorrow
cuz that's a little bit but she could
direct so I'll dream up and I'll say
building a rapport hi I'd always start
by saying I've got HMO close by but not
super close so for instance Grimsby you
can say oh I've been doing HMOs for a
while I'm a bit outside of the area
maybe you called or whatever and I'm
buying a property in Grimsby close to
you and I just wondered if it might work
as a multi layer because got four
bedrooms but I'm looking at Boyan
and let's let's get your advice so it's
in Church Road or wherever and do you
think that would work
chance them if they think it would be
you've got a bit of rapport going you
could say you know what I feel really
cheeky right now but I've actually got a
viewing on it I've not seen it myself
I've talked to the agent I've got the
funds for it I still have you on it
tomorrow
I don't suppose he's really cheeky and
I've been very happy to pay you and
cover your expenses but I don't suppose
that you could maybe nip by and have a
look for me and give me some feedback I
mean I totally understand if not as I
say I'm more than happy to cover your
expenses and if it does go through and I
complete on it and you think you're a
bit bit more to that and you've given me
some good advice on it then of course
I'll give it you to match what what do
you think and then boom you've got a
winner builder same story ring up a
builder and you're gonna say hey do you
work in the groomers B area yes I do
great do you work on Church roads coz
I'm buying a property of there yes I do
excellent you know I don't think any too
much work and now I'd love to get you
out to have a look at that I'm gonna be
upfront with you I haven't actually
bought it yet it's still it's still
going through so you know it's not even
how to even you know date or anything
it's on the market but before I put an
offer on I don't know how much I'm going
to I need to spend on to do it up so if
you could go up for me I'm more than
happy to pay you in cover your costs to
go and quote but I could definitely use
you as the Builder if it goes through I
mean how does that sound I just say he
just talks people build relationships
another way to get runners go network in
there's lots of people that would love
to you know that absolutely love to view
lots of properties that are potential
hexamers they don't know what a
potential hexamer quite looks like as
long as you get everyone to go out to
fill out the feedback form so they move
through the whole checklist think you
could I'd often be on the phone when
they're there so you can ask some
questions make sure to fill out the the
form properly so you know how much work
needs to be done you know Farscape
windows all that kinda stuff
actually there's HMO but that ladies and
gentlemen is how you can very easily get
runners in any area in the country which
saves you having to go and leave reduce
your time like Crozet do get yourself as
well especially when you fill in the
initial days you want to go you want to
get filthy air you wanna go networking
but hey if you can leave with your time
by using somebody else's it is well
worth
great no that's excellent and what were
you all gonna call out these are notes
if we end up doing work will absolutely
pass the work to you but at the same
time on it okay okay yeah no I really
appreciate that and my name is Samuel
water why your name Kent
alright great stuff Kent thank you ever
so much pop in your diary I drop me a
text feedback details and lots of space
of you tomorrow and that is how you get
a runner easy-peasy
okay well I actually have a runner
already within about half an hour I've
got a few other really interesting
contacts to I'll show you what I did
text people saying this I text landlords
in the area who are renting their own
property out on spare room I might go on
buying a property in DM 32 and wondered
if you'd be interested in helping me
with it
thanks I'm the landlord that's close by
of course it is a little bit of
competition but everyone loves to help
humans are kind usually so they this one
is Shallon responded i takes about six
levels hi what did you want to know and
i said two things I'd love to chat about
the market generally as I've only
invested in hope obvious that's not
quite true but it's a little bit of
roleplay and secondly I have a viewing
tomorrow at 1:30 and I'm desperately
looking for someone to cover as I can't
make yet happy to pay to cover the time
yes I found your content on spare room
she responded and said well you know I
have experience I only went up one room
but I do know the good bad news about
your experience in that area will be
better than mine and I've just had a
phone call with her she's going out
tomorrow and so just be creative get
contacting people find property
investors find letting agents builders
phone them make touch and just make sure
that when they go they do a good job
they fill out the check form properly
there we have it